de sainz
are those who work in bolivia neither
bass nor singers only make
our ship black they form deficiencies and
that he came rodin to instruct medicaid is located
is white soccer player
[Music]
because the only sport of playing
soccer I enjoy doing it from a very
young age and I follow it  trying to do every
time a court is built
there is always that when I get tired of
enjoying it or not my freedom playing bad
future I am not going to do it I do it because
I like it because it was always like that and the
only thing that interests me is
to wish to inform you I would like to know how
you do it to keep motivated the
possible titles
I would like you to arrive much more
I always said that one year a
group objective is to achieve everything because of
the bar we are in, which is this club that
always aspires to everyone
mentality of finishing my career with
many titles  the more the better
hector calderón that in terms of feet
the technician who was there said the
same thing from heaven the boy said this what  and it
comes from outside it cannot stay here
I here is the kick and it can be
found 22 lanes away but the
technician as long as he delivered and been to
this end and still if you are
inside you
never told him anything a visionary
guy
arrived you will feel those  that in addition to being
in a locker room that stallone in Catalan
or so that she doesn't have much life
afterwards we entered the field that
made her feel I also know if the field
also gives you not the touch in the
games
but the issue of the troops so much  Once
when the new thing was approved, you don't
want it to stay, you're going to take it
away from one of your friends, but it's
between jumps,
fritz,
not you, with excess exteriors, the iris,
I think they're going to want to outdo me,
always loving the mother of  to be
the number one critic of myself and to
know when when now known in
when he speaks normal work thing ilo
steve or what does it feel like to hear
that you're probably probably the
best  player of all history it
is something impressive to be able to hear
that yes it is the fact
that what follows is thought for me is a
great pride but extracting it is a
truth that I try not to stop to
think about it but to live day by day  in
enjoying everything that I have to
go through and thinking about not asking and what it
feels like to be a player with more ballon
d'or or something little like just recently it is something very
nice to be able to receive this award for
what it means to have received
the fifth  a little while ago, but
this year they are trying to repeat
with this step, barcelona
told me that they have played the ball for a long time
and it is not worth that much,
he told me
[Music]
aníbal bets on the field
late they
know well
[Music]
I am not happy  because of how they get to
this last time because of the number of
goals I've scored but I
always say that it doesn't
matter how important the team is with this
dynamic with this game
trying to get a title  that at
the end of the day it is important
that they enjoy that they take advantage of all
the opportunities that
and try in barcelona that they take advantage of
every situation every minute of what they
can get to experience here being
lucky enough to be in a clan is not so
great as it is is how this sport is made
in the opportunity that it gives you not
only in football but in
later life the possibility of being able to study
after growing up and being able to educate and I
think the important thing is to take advantage of
all that and then enjoy  of soccer
and being as professional as possible
playing that when there are children he
was a boy who loved the ball a lot
who played in the street at school in
a neighborhood club
and dreams of being a professional
[Music]
hey this is not because it was  Very
young, the only thing I wanted was to play
wherever and when I grew up, my
only
dream was to dream of the first division in
Argentina because I was in Argentina and
after that, when I was here in
Barcelona.  a but no i didn't think about our
titles just
today no no because things happened like this
because it had
to be like this i don't regret anything on the
contrary i am very grateful to
barcelona
for trusting me when i was
very young for giving me the opportunity and  for
making me the player that I am
nobody everis versions that follow me
high in place saint at work
non-violent psychic portfolio on board the
center of tripoli the cndh in question
are demonstrating is washington
should not have action in your business
or your life building  involved in three
issues along the way he exposes here we
go questioned one big three the version
used by plane something ingested resident in m
soccer soccer
audio soccer in south africa in
no law in germ critical experienced
many things both good and
bad which I  it helped me grow as a
person as a professional
I became a father which is a
huge change it makes you see things differently
today my daughter comes first  jo and then
everyone else will come to my house and see I'll see
friends a great joy that you have
forgotten
everything everything bad I think
that instead
[Applause]
[Music]
grass
like that
is so
simple well not
the one pension software branch or the
sars red
and live a love section soccer be
jacket i have idea in christian ronaldo
the striker in extreme infiniti berlin
- and the one of mafalda the way in very even sets the
way the work was good